[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we are here to discuss satisfaction
and the buyer 150 years ago life was
short and luxuries scarce by comparison
ours is an affluent society where most
have enough and plenty working-class
Victorian women had only one dress today
we have so many clothes that an average
of 77 percent of our wardrobe is not
worn in any one year and half are never
worn at all why then do so many of us
remain unsatisfied spending our lives
feeling unfulfilled and chasing evermore
is it nature to be dissatisfied with our
a lot in life do we need discontent to
drive us to succeed and to innovate to
better our own lives and those around us
or is our dissatisfaction a form of
greed encouraged by a relentlessly
material culture that is not good for
our own well-being and that of the
planet and should we as a result engage
in a radical overhaul in our goals and
values with me to discuss this today are
four wonderful speakers we've got guys
standing to my right he's an economist
he's most widely known for his work on
universal basic income which I'm sure
you've heard lots about he's currently
working with the Labour Shadow
Chancellor John McDonald on plans to
roll this out in the United Kingdom is
the author of too many best-selling
books to mention but most recently
plunder of the Commons a manifesto for
sharing wealth also to my right we have
mark Littlewood he's a libertarian
economist so obviously we're gonna have
a good fight to my rights over here a
libertarian economist who believes that
if you don't enjoy the materialism of
society today you have the option to go
and live in a cave if you wish
he is the director-general of the
Institute of Economic Affairs and
futures regularly on BBC question time
news night Sky News and The Today
program to my left
we've got Isabella Kaminsky who comes to
economics by way of ancient history
which she studied at UCL she's now
editor of FT Alphaville a daily news and
commentary service for the financial
markets professionals created by the
Financial Times and he needs no
introduction but I'm gonna do it anyways
because nothing makes a British person
squirm more than being praised in public
commonly described as one as popular
music's most innovative figures Brian
Eno is a musician record producer visual
artist and theorist best known for his
pioneering work in ambient music and
contributions to rock pop and
electronica earlier this year Brian Eno
was inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall
of Fame so Joe does the success of the
economy depend on desire and greed guy
standing the floor is yours
well I find the question actually almost
impossible to answer so I should
actually shut up at this point but but I
do want to make a few points that relate
to it the sense of constant
dissatisfaction is something that we
know exists quite commonly but we must
take a class perspective on these issues
some people have the luxury of being
able to have all these shorts and
dresses and things in their wardrobe
that I mentioned in the preamble but if
you're in the precariat today just let
me give you one statistic which in real
is their reality one in every three
people who are in rented accommodation
today in this country when they've paid
their rent and they paid their food have
only 23 pounds left for everything else
they have to spend
these people are living on the breadline
with debts that are basically
unsustainable we have higher personal
debt today than at any time in our
history it's worth 87 percent of GDP so
you've got a growing precariat and the
homeless and rough sleepers who are
being subject to insecurity and at the
same time we have a situation where we
need a new politics of time every age
has had its stupidity about what is work
and what is not work our age is the most
stupid in history
Arthur P GU an economist I'm an
economist other people famously said
that he vide hired a woman as a
housekeeper or a cook national income
went up economic growths went up
employment went up the unemployment rate
went down and then if he married her and
she continued to do precisely the same
work national income went down economic
growth went down employment went down
and the unemployment rate went up and we
still suffer from having Labor
Statistics which give a completely
distorted picture of how people have to
live and if you're in the precariat you
have to do a hell of a lot of work for
labour work for the state work for
filling in forms work for applying for
benefits or dealing with sanctions or
all sorts of other things filling in
your resume a for the 39th time people
are under pressure and stress and we
need to capture a different way of life
and one of the simplest things that we
could do is overhaul our Labor
Statistics so we have a better picture
of how people are being forced to behave
because we have an epidemic of stress of
dissatisfied people who are feeling they
have no time I call them the must
somewhere else generation we've all
qualified with for an MB se degree you
don't feel you are content with doing it
and it reminds me of the ancient Greeks
and the ancient aphorisms that went at
the time Cato famously said never is a
man more active than when he's doing
nothing and Henry Thoreau Toro in the
19th century when he went to live in a
cabin he said my greatest gift is for
want so little we have to have a new
approach which enables us to be lazy
Aristotle regarded a civilized person as
someone who had access to a gia laziness
we puritanical people have turned
laziness into some sort of crime the
politicians say oh he's lazy
as if laziness is some parasitic
activity we need laziness and we only if
we have control of our time
will we learn to live differently learn
to smell the roses learn to appreciate
the butterflies learn to get reconnected
with nature reread Alexander von
Humboldt from the 19th century to see
that connectivity and only then can we
deal with the billboards that shout at
us to spend and spend and spend I've
just been in Warsaw and there is nothing
more annoying than seeing a thirty
square metre billboard in the centre of
Warsaw showing rafa nadal in his
underpants telling us we must buy those
Underpants and we will look like Rafa
Nadal we are subject to a loss of our
landscape Commons those billboards and
advertisements telling us that we're
inadequate we need more we need more we
need more what we need to get rid of
that scrap and I think we've got to
realize that
only if we can slow down only if we can
get a control of our time so that we can
care for one another the care work we do
not in the statistics we need to have a
different perspective on life and then
we will want less that's what I have
[Applause]
marna help sorry three brisk minutes
well I was surprised to hear that
politicians keep denouncing us as lazy
and idle and the rest of it I actually
get a bit frustrated because all I ever
hear from politicians when they are
describing families or nurses or people
in the military are hardworking families
apparently this is now a mandatory
adjective to put in front of everybody
yeah we're on the side of hard-working
families politicians across the spectrum
say this I've never decided who to vote
for because I don't know who's standing
up for idle single people like myself
nobody's making a pitch people like you
you get out of bed late and don't really
work very hard who's standing over there
all the opposite they're all telling us
how hard we are working and they're not
I dare say there are lots of people who
work very hard I've actually decided
what I want in my life is to lower my
number of hours per week I have enough
sort of material stuff I still want more
but the the question we were asked was
are we permanently is human nature is it
human nature to be set this satisfied or
is it encouraged by a relentless
material culture and I think the answer
that question is both but but I think
I'm probably in favor of both I think
human dissatisfaction is probably a good
thing I don't mean human misery
I mean striving for better than you have
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas